in january 2020 saiyan uber ride from
new york city's john f kennedy airport
to midtown manhattan cost about 50
today based on the average price rise of
uber rides that same trip could be 75
about a 50 jump you may have noticed
this too according to data from racketed
intelligence the average uber and lyft
fare in the us rose month to month from
february through july breaking records
each time
in july 2021 consumers paid over 50
percent more per ride compared with
january 2020. all these customers are
complaining that they are actually
paying more for their rides the biggest
factor that's driving prices up has to
do with the pandemic but prices are
slowly beginning to rise even before the
pandemic to all the viewers seeing this
don't expect dirt cheap prices uh the
way that we had before the pandemic
here's why your uber and lyft rides are
going through the roof and why they
might not ever come all the way back
down to where they once were
ride prices are higher for customers
right now especially during the pandemic
because there is that shortage of
drivers and increased demand harry
kampal an uber and lyft driver runs a
popular blog called rideshare guy
drivers like many others had a huge um
you know impact by the pandemic and i
think really what we saw at the start
was demand for ride hail really just
fell off the cliff in early 2020
bookings for uber rise declined 75
percent as americans hunker down for the
pandemic as states have opened back up
the demand for rides has returned faster
than the supply of drivers resulting in
price hikes in many cities across the us
experts say that prices are taking a
while to return to normal for a few
reasons i think the number one factor
why drivers haven't come back to uber
and lyft and why we're seeing this
shortage on the supply side still to
this day is because of unemployment
insurance some states are still paying
unemployment benefits but in states that
have stopped benefits uber and lyft are
seeing drivers return and prices go down
uber has said that they've seen uh
prices come down in places like miami
houston and atlanta whereas big cities
like new york san francisco and la
prices are still high there because
drivers haven't returned uber said 90 of
the 90 000 inactive drivers they
surveyed in june indicated they plan to
return by september when unemployment
benefits expire in most states another
factor keeping prices up ride share
companies aren't just competing for
drivers amongst themselves they're also
competing with food delivery services
which drivers say offer safer work
conditions actually traditionally uh
driving for hire has always been a
pretty dangerous job you really don't
know who's getting into your car at all
times i mean i think the cdc
recommendation was to stay six feet away
from people and as soon as someone gets
into your car they're breaking that rule
so a lot of gig workers have switched
over to delivery services and found that
they liked it riders on the other hand
are back on the road than droves as
rider demand has increased both uber and
lyft increased driver bonuses earlier
this year to attract more drivers back
to the platform
in april uber announced it was
allocating 250 million dollars in an
effort to boost driver availability lyft
spent 572 million on driver incentives
through the second quarter of 2021 for
now these incentives seem to be working
according to lyft more drivers are
coming back to the platform in recent
months as drivers return to the roads
uber and lyft hope that prices will
stabilize but they'll probably never be
as cheap as they typically were in the
last decade
there are a few reasons for this
for one uber and lyft had begun phasing
out discounts to riders even before the
pandemic what started happening before
the pandemic is that pressure started to
build from investors investors started
saying you have to have a sustainable
model to
future profits uber and lyft have been
using a subsidy model since the very
beginning and that model is fairly
simple startups raise venture capital
and use those funds to attract customers
with deep discounts these subsidies
could come in many forms from low
shipping rates for e-commerce sites to
coupons for free food delivery for
ride-hailing companies like uber and
lyft subsidies have involved attracting
riders with big discounts and then
incentivizing drivers to provide those
rides but in recent years the companies
have begun phasing out those rider
discounts they are not profitable
companies they lose money nearly every
year we don't know when they will turn a
net profit for now rideshare companies
are still offering drivers incentives as
a way of making driving more attractive
for the long haul given the ongoing
challenges however uber said that their
driver numbers have increased to a point
where they'll be pulling back on driver
incentives moving forward the company's
near-term challenge is keeping drivers
after that the bonus pay every single
week might be 30 of a driver's pay so
you could imagine that if they
completely got rid of these bonuses one
day and drivers saw their pay cut by 30
you'd have a huge exodus of drivers at a
time where the companies are already
struggling to match supply and match
demand so companies are thinking of new
ways to make driving more attractive one
of the things that uber began doing is
that it started offering free
online language classes for drivers the
company says you know a lot of their
drivers are immigrants english is not
their first language so this could be a
tool that they could use to move up the
ladder and develop new skills also
adding to the cost of rides when
regulatory changes like prop 22 went
into effect in late 2020 companies
shifted some of the financial burden to
customers
if consumers want
uh better benefits for drivers then we
should also be willing to pay slightly
more both uber and lyft are focusing
more on long-term profits analysts say
consumers should expect to pay more per
ride compared to the discounted rates
before the pandemic i think that they
probably weren't paying you know the
full cost of the fare in a lot of these
situations and kind of getting a good
deal riders may have to pay a little bit
more for their rides and they may not
like it but hopefully they'll find
solace in the fact that you know drivers
um you know are getting uh you know part
of that ride for consumers ride share
prices probably will not stay at their
current heights however you probably
won't see those low subsidized prices
again anytime soon